c'est la fête dans cette érable hier qui
ouvre ses portes en fin de semaine
pendant qu'une partie de l'équipe
accueille la visite une autre prépare la
récolte d'eau d'érable qui débutera dès
que le printemps le voudra bien
des années ça a commencé plutôt mais il
y a vraiment plus de plan de matchs
qu'on peut faire d'avance pour aider
l'entreprise des équipements
ultramodernes comme cet appareil qui
informe le producteur et les
scientifiques de la coulée en temps réel
ce qu'on appelle des érablières
intelligentes faites mettons moi quand
je vais être à Montréal ou sur la route
je vais pouvoir voir ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui notre production jusqu'à
maintenant on avait des connaissances
sur la quantité de sirop ou de Sèvres
produites dans une certaine année mais
ça c'est pas suffisant pour expliquer la
dynamique journalière
l'équipe de recherche sur Viber en
heures le débit de sève dans les
tubulures pour mieux les comparer à des
données recueillies directement en forêt
comme la température du sol et le
diamètre on veut aussi mesurer les
variables qui ont un impact sur la
saveur du sirop si on arrive vraiment à
optimiser à améliorer la qualité de la
de la sève en tant que matière première
donc on arrive finalement à améliorer la
qualité des sirops parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de neige qui protègent les
plantes Lucas a aussi planté entre 400
et 500 petits érables provenant de 37 du
Canada et des États-Unis une forêt
similaire a été plantée en Outaouais
pour comparer les données les chercheurs
vont par exemple évaluer l'impact des
gelées tardives sur les variétés qui se
réveillent tôt au printemps qu'est-ce
qu'il va se passer dans les années
est-ce qu'ils vont
profiter de leur plus longue saison où
il pourrait être endommagé plus
fréquemment en tant que producteur ce
que je vais voir c'est est-ce que je
produis plus via les réchauffements
climatique est-ce que ma saison est plus
propice certaines données auront un
impact rapide pour optimiser la qualité
et la quantité du sirop mais il faudra
attendre au moins 10 ans pour mieux
déterminer comment préserver la santé
des érablières à long terme ici gel
manager Radio-Canada Saguenay